8 news now is your local election
headquarters and 2024 is shaping up to
be a rematch
this is not a time to be complaced
that's why I'm running for re-election
[Music]
the official President Joe Biden
announcing he is now running for a
second term while the president had said
he did intend to run there was some
doubts due to his age he'll be 82 if he
wins in 2024 and takes office now if the
election were held today polls show his
Challenger would be former president
Donald Trump there's more than a year
and a half between election day 2024 but
the race is already well underway if
you've been watching television you
might actually think the election was
much sooner 8 news now investigator
reporter David charns explains we're a
year and a half away from November 2024
but you may have received this Mailer in
your mailbox it's compelling Governor
Ron DeSantis to run for president if you
haven't gotten it in the mail you're
going to see something similar on TV
Catherine Cortez masto has always served
with Integrity they're part of any
political season this is Joe ads before
and against candidates wanting your vote
check the calendar
is here to stay it's not even May a full
year and a half before the 2024 election
one ad already airing compels Florida
Republican Governor Ronda santis to get
in the race former Republican Nevada
attorney general Senate candidate and
friend of DeSantis Adam laxalt is its
chair is this early it's not early in
the modern era we've been moving now
towards What's called the endless
campaign for some time now Dr Francis
Carlton is a political science professor
at CSN is this normal to see ads saying
hey please run we we want you to run
yeah not normal but we're not living in
normal times the 2022 cycle proved the
costliest in our nation's history with
more than nine billion dollars spent
that's according to open Secrets
candidates in political action
committees spent more than 300 million
dollars right here in Nevada alone
that's according to ad impact politics
what will we see in 2024 I think right
now president Trump has the inside track
for the GOP nomination and I think him
being criminally indicted in New York
actually helps him in a statement the
communications director of Never Back
Down tells the eighties out
investigators Ron DeSantis is the most
popular leader in the country right now
and many Americans don't even know his
personal story of a blue-collar
upbringing his life of hard work and
service and his work as a conservative
fighter in Winter yet Never Back Down is
starting to tell that story because this
Grassroots movement sees Governor
DeSantis as the person who should be
president in 2024. polls right now show
former president Trump in the lead for
the Republican nomination but it is very
early the primary is in February of next
year the general election that November
so a year from this November long ways
away whoever wins that primary likely
facing off against President Biden I'm
David charns 8 News Now
so while President Biden and former
president Trump are likely to face off
again in 2024 a Yahoo news you gov poll
shows the majority of Democrats and
Republicans don't want either of them to
run both are expected though to start
airing ads in the coming weeks